le deuil ne seront pas faciles à faire
pour la famille de fredy villanueva qui
a été tué samedi par un policier l'
affaire villanueva a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre et pour la réalisatrice
sophie deraspe
ce fut l'élément déclencheur d'un projet
qu'elle caressait depuis longtemps
revisiter le mythe d'antigone la
tragédie de sophocle puis joyel toutes
les commentaires qui émanait de 2,7 à
faire valoir
villanueva avec un frère victimes des
balles d'un policier puis un autre le
plus grand fair qui lui est menacé de
déportation parce qu'il a des démêlés
avec la justice
donc j'ai comme j'ai eu cette étincelle
qui avait là comme une situation
initiale qui pouvait ressembler à celle
d' antigone
comme dans la tragédie de sophocle le
film antigone raconte la descente aux
enfers d'une adolescente brillante qui
bascule dans la criminalité après la
mort de son frère un grand frère a été
tué devant ses yeux
punir palin est jeune et pourtant qui
est juste prête à tout sacrifier par
loyauté envers sa famille la courageuse
jeune femme porte à une justice
inhumaines et impitoyable
[Musique]
à la haine antigone choisi d'opposer
l'amour un camélia la fin de printemps
tout le monde se roule dans l'herbe
je pense quand tu donnes n'est qu'amour
elle fait preuve d'amour inconditionnel
que ce soit envers ses frères ou en
verre
les individus concours qui composent le
système cycle et respirante et intègre
elle réussit à mobiliser les gens qui
l'entourent et à créer un élan de
solidarité gérer la loi mais je
recommencerai demain parce que mon coeur
me dit des démons frère
antigone est une tragédie moderne
remarquable après s'être illustré au
tiff le film représente le canada dans
la course aux oscars
c'est comme une campagne électorale faut
aller chercher des appuis il faut se
faire voir
deux mille cinq cents ans après sa
création le mythe d'antigone continue de
résonner avec force et pertinence fesc
dessina by alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal